probably I still need to play the new
Zelda that comes out before I get yeah
yeah that's that's what I've been doing
I'm not touching that today are you not
touching that I think I'm gonna chill
out for a little bit I'm good
I know I know it's good I just is it as
good as people are making it out to be
is it better than breath of the wild
it's like I don't know it's obviously a
direct sequel
um like it literally takes place right
after the events of the first game yeah
uh but kind of also is like the law
behind it is also like kind of
pre-quilly as well so like the it's it's
the events that are happening in real
time are after the first game but the
story is more so about before the first
game is the story better I think the
story is a lot better okay for sure I
think I think the story in the second
game is a lot better because you
actually like get to find out more about
like Zelda and um you know the kind of
state of Hyrule at the time and like
Ganon in this game is just so he's such
a Chad he's he's so hot I'm just saying
it right now I'm saying it right now
this like because this full is full on
voice acting now and and Ganon and like
all these characters are like just full
on talking and the Japanese voice does
link talk uh no links
as he usually does but like uh when you
go to like certain areas in the game
where you can uh pinpoint pieces of
Zelda's past uh there's just full voice
acted cutscenes and ganon's voice
gannon's Japanese voice is [__] hot
I'm just gonna say it outright it's
[__] badass do you sound like joto I
imagine you sound like jotra he's like a
cross between Johto and Dio yeah well
it's it's [__] badass yeah but like
um the the power-ups are completely
different now that you get like so like
breath of the wild there's like a lot of
it had to do with like using bombs yeah
right and the Chica slate stuff uh this
time it's way more like I guess craft
based yeah it's like nuts and bolts it's
like Minecraft basically yeah I saw like
the vehicle building like system that
they had and that looks like a lot of
fun yeah using that in like all the
temples to like kind of basically craft
[__] to get over certain puzzles is so
[__] satisfying when you get it right
and just some of the [__] I've seen on
Twitter
is gonna beat that game in 10 seconds
yeah like some of the [__] I've seen on
Twitter of people making these like
insane Contraptions and like I saw a
Japanese did on Twitter who just made
like a full-on Gundam holy [__] like he
made like a functioning Gundam that just
[__] walks and shoots lasers through
his hands and [__] just destroys about
Goblin Billy and so it's just like I
feel like the creative side of like
breath of the wild is just like
Amplified tenfold in this new game
people have been really creative about
how to torch a [__] Crocs oh whatever
right yeah I've seen so many Twitter
Twitter memes and Twitter threads being
like this is uh how we've committed war
crimes against korons here a thread
isn't it the same map as breath of the
wild it's pretty much the same map but
now there's like an extra layer above it
and an extra lay below so now it's it's
literally like Minecraft where it's like
the they have like kind of this
underground layer which is an exact copy
of the the surface but it's like the
nether in Minecraft so you go down and
like the enemies are harder it's harder
to heal they're more resource and stuff
like that and then there's also islands
in the sky that you can fly up to and
there's like extra little layers there
so the world is like three times bigger
now
I just know it's gonna be a dick dude I
know that's I've been playing it for the
fast like I think I've already sunk like
40 50 hours into that game yeah it
sounds like it's even bigger than a
breath of the wild which I already put
enough hours in yeah
um other puzzles any better because I
know like one of the big criticisms was
that oh you know the you know it's
missing the Zelda magic because the
puzzle's aren't as good as they were
before
um I think the puzzles in this one at
least for me personally are a little bit
more challenging because you do have to
kind of get more creative yeah with the
puzzle I mean some some of the puzzles
are like just a walk in the park where
it's just like more of a tutorial on how
to use certain abilities and [__] but
like some puzzles I was like
legitimately stuck on for like a long
time like others like others I literally
just had to like cheese it just being
like I'm pretty sure this is not the
intended way of doing it but I still got
through it I think they know that I
think yeah I know that you can cheese it
and that's I think that's part of the
joy right I think so yeah the game is
fun it's like all I'm pretty sure this
isn't the way I was supposed to do it
but I still did it yeah yeah it's pretty
high I feel like you're smarter than the
game yeah exactly yeah exactly like
Zelda like breath of the wild uh
especially and you know the new game as
well it just seems like a game built for
speedrunners oh yeah speedrunners are
like frothing at the mouth being like
how can we break this game in the most
efficient way possible I mean I think
like the breath of the wild 80 Speed Run
is like 20 something minutes or
something yeah it's just like stupid to
watch it's just like I've never seen a
game from like the modern era be that
[__] destroyed by speedrunners wait
ever it is it is beautiful to watch yeah
I just I I really want to play I I do
really want to play it's just I also
want a life as well I don't know I know
it's like one or the other which is the
big reason why I still haven't played
Elden ring it's just like it's it's
those games where like I know once I
start I I'm not stopping until I finish
it I mean that's why I was like kind of
dreading uh you know stepping into
honkai yeah because I was like I already
am obsessed with one game yeah that game
itself I do not want to balance the
other game okay but like the thing and
the thing okay part of the reason I am
into games like honkai and uh you know
um Genji and stuff like that it's
because
are they are they better games than
other AAA games out there I would say
you know especially genshin no you know
it's gen Xin is not better than
something like breath of the wild but is
it more manageable to play through a
game like that for me at least for me
then AAA game that I'm going to spend
hours and hours in yes it is more
manageable I can load up honka on my
phone and I could play for a little bit
and uh that's no issue at all you know
when I get into a game like Zelda or
Elden ring I'm like there for eight
hours yeah that's not like the game I
feel like they always trick you like
game mobile games like that because like
you've it's like how
sometimes you think that like watching a
YouTube video is easier and more
convenient than watching Netflix or
something because you think that like oh
I can just pause at any time and stop
yeah and it's it's low low risks it's a
it's not a big thing it's like a AAA
movie right yeah but but I think you end
up pretty spending more time playing
like honkai or gentian or whatever in
like because you feel like it's so easy
to play it oh yeah yeah I mean just
because you feel at any time you can
stop and there's no pressure you know
what I mean yeah I feel like because
they allow you and almost encourage you
and it's advertised in a way and the
game feels low low stakes so you don't
feel like oh I'm gonna just I'm gonna
play a little bit and then you play for
like five hours I mean I mean ring is
more like okay I'm committing to this
boss yeah yeah like like for me for me
that's that's the that's what makes
gacha games so I guess appealing to me
is that there is that choice there is
that choice between like okay sometimes
I just want to grind out the story of
Hong Kong and I play for like five hours
or something that's great and then
sometimes I just I can just load up my
phone do like a single side quest uh and
then that's that's completely fine as
well I'm always making some kind of
progress and depending on what my
schedule is like what my life is like at
the time it always fits the schedule
like no matter what and that's what
makes it just so much more accessible
and the fact that you can play it
[__] anywhere you can play it on PC I
sound like an ad read right now but that
genuinely that generally is why I play
them you know because it's just suited
towards uh towards my gaming stuff I
just need that experience though that
blows your mind and that's like Allison
ring as long as you need that
I don't know like okay life-changing
experience okay back back to the hashtag
ad but honkai has like genuinely
surprised me I I genuinely think it is a
good game with moments that I did not
expect from a gacha game like there were
moments later in the story which I'm not
gonna spoil but but like made me like
genuine like holy [__] this is not just
Gadget game good this is just like good
good now and it's it's it's like I it
worries me as well just because it's
making a [__] ton of money and while I
do like honkai
um I don't want every game in the gaming
industry to be to be like a gadget game
because at the moment right now honkai
feels more like a triple a game with
gatch elements right which I don't know
I mean I I think the the turn-based
combat when that's happening I'm like oh
this is good and we go to the Overworld
I'm like oh
you know what I mean like it's I think
it's a great game it was fun yeah like
yeah it was just like oh it's just like
super limited and very like I don't know
it didn't
didn't feel that I haven't played enough
to say any opinion but like from the
little I did play last night on stream
um yeah I I I've kind of I'm a little
bit on Corner side in that instance
where I like the the actual gameplay
like battle elements yeah I think that's
like really polished incredible oh yeah
yeah they've crushed it on the
turn-based combat yeah turn this combat
feel
kind of exciting yeah uh which I like
because normally I'm I don't like
turn-based comebacks it's boring yeah um
but they've done it in a way that feels
pretty active
um and yeah it's very flashy yeah I made
the joke on stream yesterday where I was
like oh finally I can play a tone-based
RPG and not have a dead stream
because you play any other turn based
RPG game 's on stream and it just does
no you can't play like a Final Fantasy
on on you know stream and it do well
consistently I mean yeah like I've just
played the RPG as well right that's
turn-based combat and that did life I
mean it sounds [__] weird to praise a
dismemberment system but that was a a
kind of gameplay that was kind of
exciting yeah yeah yeah there was that
tension there right yeah and it's Unique
if you get hit there was consequences
yes in a lot of turbos combat and Conor
mcent too I don't really [__] give a
[__] if I die yeah there's no
consequences for dying or failing a
fight so I I rarely care yeah yeah I
yeah like I I think I'm starting to get
sold on turn-based combat I there are
still some systems like it's it's so
join us I mean it's so weird right
because I really really like the honkai
turn-based combat system because but
that's just because it's there's
something about it that just feels so
satisfying and I don't know why it's
really satisfying maybe is the
flashiness maybe is my monkey brain go
oh pretty colors
the alts are pretty [__] flashy yeah
yeah because the thing is it's not that
complicated compared to other turn-based
combat systems I've played in fact it's
a very very similar to the trails series
which I got into before you look at
Final Fantasy and you're like how many
[__] magic spells do I have and yeah
I gotta manage all the the Buffs and
debuff like the whole car is like two
yeah yeah and and I would say this you
know as someone who's like now finished
the first two games of like the trails
series I [__] hate the combat system
man it is it is uh it's turn based and
it's more complex than honkai but I just
find it boring man it is to me it's just
boring and I don't I don't know why
um maybe it is maybe I am just a basic
ass gamer who wants pretty colors and
nice music but that that to me like
that's important music music is such a
big factor in whether I enjoy video
games especially if I'm doing something
as mindless as like turn-based combat
yeah that's why Persona is the ghost
yeah yeah that's why persona it's the
whole reason why I'm like one thing I'll
say like honkai has
some great music
well they did not have to go that high
the boss theme they did not have to go
that hard this is pretty good yeah